a woman accused of murdering her son and  leaving his body near mountain springs  is still in a denver jail  samantha moreno rodriguez was arrested  in denver last week  she faces a murder charge in the death  of seven-year-old liam husted  still no word from metro police on the  cause of liam's death  but last night liam's father and loved  ones held a vigil at sunset park here in  the valley  everyone dressed in red and white liam's  favorite colors  nick houstead traveled from the family's  home in california for the memorial here  he says he is grateful for the  community's response  you know to take him under your wing  like like he was your own  when i wasn't able to be here with him  you know really means a lot to me and i  know he  i know he appreciates it liam's father  created a gofundme page to help with  expenses it's now grown to more than 20  thousand dollars we have a link to that  at 8newsnow.com